Herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe Nummer 20. Und ja jetzt bin ich wieder in Berlin, denn auch mein Gesprächspartner von heute kommt aus Berlin, arbeitet in Berlin, und zwar auch für den Stifterverband für die deutsche Wissenschaft, der ja auch eine Niederlassung hier direkt am Potsdamer Platz hat, ich begrüße Pascal Hetze. Hallo.
Hallo schönen guten Tag.
Wir möchten uns heute über Geld unterhalten. Oder sagen wir mal über Finanzierung, das klingt ja dann schon gleich ein bisschen weniger verwerflich. Das ist nämlich Ihr Bereich im Stifterverband richtig?
Einer der Bereiche auf jeden Fall. Ohne Geld geht natürlich nichts in der Wissenschaft. Wo geht schon was ohne Geld. Und wenn wir uns um die Rahmenbedingungen für Forschung, Innovation, Wissenschaft, Bildung beschäftigen wollen und das wollen wir, dann müssen wir natürlich auch über die grundlegenden Bedingungen reden, nämlich wie finanzieren wir das Ganze.
Welchen Weg haben Sie denn so persönlich genommen, um an der Stelle zu landen?
Ja gestartet bin ich natürlich in der Wissenschaft selber in der Hochschule. Bin dann, nachdem ich in München erst mal studiert habe, nach Rostock gegangen, sozusagen die größtmögliche Distanz zurückzulegen, die man in Deutschland zurücklegen kann.
Ja stimmt, was haben Sie denn studiert?
Volkswirtschaft. Und war dann in Rostock an einem Lehrstuhl, der sich auch mit Innovationstheorie beschäftigt hat, also Wachstum, Konjunktur und welche Rolle spielen Innovationen eigentlich dafür und wie kann ich da Beschäftigung stärken und generieren, wie kann ich Wachstum generieren durch Innovation? Das ist natürlich alles sehr auf einem abstrakten Level, wie die Volkswirte das meistens tun, mit vielen Formeln und Gleichungen. Und bin danach an einem Institut gelandet, was eigentlich eine ganz interessante Konstruktion war, das war nämlich die erste Kooperation von einer Hochschule, einer Universität mit einem Max-Planck-Institut. Das ist in Rostock entstanden zum Thema demografischer Wandel.
Welche Hochschule war das dann?
Die Universität Rostock.
Universität okay.
Und dieses Institut, Rostocker Zentrum zur Forschung des demografischen Wandels, das war so komplex wie der Name auch. Das hat sich also das Ziel gesetzt, politikrelevante Forschung in dem Feld zu betreiben. Also Max-Planck-Institut natürlich eher grundlagenorientiert. Die Hochschule, die Universität eher grundlagenorientiert. Und dieses Zentrum sollte die Erkenntnisse, die in den beiden Institutionen gewonnen werden, in praktische Politikempfehlungen auch ein Stück weit ummünzen. Und das war sehr interessant, diesen Aufbau dann auch mitzuerleben. Ich hatte da auch die Rolle eines wissenschaftlichen Koordinators, also war so in einer Zwitterposition. Habe noch ein bisschen Forschung gemacht. War aber viel damit auch beschäftigt, die Grundstrukturen für dieses Institut letztendlich mich aufzubauen.
Habe also Wissenschaft von beiden Seiten erlebt. Selber Wissenschaft machen, welche Schwierigkeiten man da manchmal hat und wie komplex es aber auch manchmal ist, Wissenschaft zu managen. Weil da die professionellen Strukturen eigentlich noch sehr schwach ausgeprägt sind. Es ist viel Learning by Doing und gerade wenn so unterschiedliche Institutionen auch zusammenkommen, wie an Universität und Max-Planck-Institut, das war schon sehr spannend zu sehen, wie da unterschiedliche Kulturen auch zusammengehen.
Wie bringt man das denn zusammen?
Indem man viel mit den Leuten redet. Also es war ehrlich gesagt das erste Jahr sehr viel Überzeugungsarbeit auf beiden Seiten, um auch den Wert dieser gemeinsamen Arbeit bekannt zu machen. Und versuchen möglichst konkrete Projekte dann auch zu organisieren, damit die Leute auch sehen, was kann man eigentlich damit erreichen.
Finde ich jetzt gerade ganz interessant, wir hatten ja hier vor einigen Ausgaben, Ausgabe 15, das Thema Wissenschaftsmanagement auch so ein bisschen im Fokus mit Muriel Helbig, die ja auch aus dem Wissenschaftsmanagement an die Spitze der Hochschule gekommen ist und da war das auch so eine der Fragestellungen, wie kriegt man den wissenschaftlichen Betrieb auch organisatorisch, also vom Management her nach vorne, weil die bisherigen Strukturen allein das nicht unbedingt tragen. Also insbesondere nicht die Anforderungen bei solchen neuen Schöpfungen auch, bei so einem Institut könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man da einfach auch anders herangehen muss, einfach weil man auch ganz andere Ergebnisse erzielt. Also in dem Moment, wo man sagt, wir wollen konkret politische Ergebnisse haben, muss man auch anders arbeiten oder stelle ich mir das falsch vor?
Nein, absolut. Und es gibt natürlich viele Wissenschaftler, die auch da gewisse Berührungsängste haben, dass ihre Ergebnisse falsch interpretiert werden, wenn man sie versucht, zu sehr zuzuspitzen und ein Stück weit Zuspitzung gehört immer dazu, wenn man das auch verständlich machen will. Sorgen sind jetzt auch nicht immer unberechtigt, also das führt manchmal natürlich auch dazu, dass sich jeder die Ergebnisse raussucht, die er dann gerne haben möchte. Und gerade zu der Zeit war Demografie, demografischer Wandel natürlich auch ein hochpolitisches Thema. Ich würde sagen, es hat sich alles jetzt auch ein bisschen entspannt und versachlicht, aber damals gingen ja auch diese ganzen Schlagworte, Überalterung der Gesellschaft und wir sterben aus und gab es dann die Zeitungen, die berechnet haben, wann der letzte Deutsche irgendwie beerdigt wird. Also wir sehen, so dramatisch ist es ja alles nicht mehr, aber da war natürlich auch viel Feuer in der Debatte. Das hat es aber auch spannend gemacht natürlich.
Und wie führte dann der Weg zum Stifterverband?
Über den Umweg des Bundespräsidialamtes, also dann von der Wissenschaft erst mal in die politische Administration, was insofern dann einigermaßen nahe lag, weil ich ja dann schon im Rostocker Zentrum auch so politisch relevant gearbeitet habe. Und der Bundespräsident hat damals ein Kooperationsprogramm mit der Bertelsmann-Stiftung zum demografischen Wandel. Und da durfte ich dann mitarbeiten.
Walten. Okay. Also da war sozusagen das Thema dann eigentlich die Vorgabe.
Da war das Thema die Brücke. Wobei wir natürlich, also für sage ich mal einen politischen Kontext relativ wissenschaftlich gearbeitet haben. Also es ging schon darum auch, das Thema auf die politische Agenda zu bringen. Wie ich ja gerade gemeint habe, das Thema Demografie, demografischer Wandel war politisch sehr aufgeladen und der Bundespräsident hatte sich damals vorgenommen, das Ganze ein bisschen mit Aufklärung zu betreiben.
Welcher Bundespräsident war das?
Das war das Köhler noch. Und da haben wir versucht, Fakten in die Welt zu bringen, anstatt nur irgendwie Gefühle.
Ist das eigentlich was normales im Bundespräsidialamt, dass solche Arbeiten gemacht werden oder war das im Prinzip ein Novum? Also dass so wissenschaftliche Aufarbeitung dort betrieben wird?
Also es gibt immer wieder gemeinsame Projekte des Bundespräsidenten mit anderen gesellschaftlichen Institutionen. Also Geschichtswettbewerb und ähnliches, aber es ist jetzt nicht die Regel würde ich sagen. Also es ist schon eher etwas ungewöhnlicheres gewesen.
Aber der demografische Wandel war jetzt nicht unbedingt der Grund, beim Stifterverband anzuheuern?
Nein. Wobei es natürlich da auch wieder Brücken gibt, weil wir uns sehr intensiv auch mit dem Thema Bildung beschäftigt haben. Weil wenn wir weniger werden, dann müssen wir besser werden als Leitsatz. Und wir haben uns also viel mit den Themen Bildung, Wissenschaft, Forschung auch da mal schon beschäftigt. Und der Stifterverband ist natürlich insofern da auch eine interessante Institution, weil er ja so an einer Schnittstelle steht, der verschiedenen gesellschaftlichen Akteure. Wir sind von der Wirtschaft getragen, unterstützen die Wissenschaft, beraten die Politik, fördern die Zivilgesellschaft oder vermessen die Zivilgesellschaft, haben also mit allen gesellschaftlichen Gruppen eng zu tun und insofern ist das also gar nicht mal so unterschiedlich von der Arbeitsweise, wie man das vielleicht auf den ersten Blick denkt.
Da kommen wir dann eigentlich auch gleich zu einem sehr aktuellen Projekt, was an der Stelle in gewisser Hinsicht auch ansetzt, also an der Vermessung zumindest. Das Hochschulbarometer, ein Projekt was Sie betreuen. Was es jetzt seit wann gibt? Seit drei Jahren?
Seit 2011 ja.
Seit 2011 und was jährlich eine Befragung durchführt im universitären Bereich. Wer wird da befragt und wonach?
Das sind nicht nur die Universitäten, sind auch die Fachhochschulen, pädagogischen, theologischen Hochschulen. Wir befragen die Hochschulleitungen, also explizit Direktoren und Präsidenten. Setzen da also an der strategischen Ebene an. Es gibt sicherlich auch viele Befragungen da der Professorenschaft, vielleicht auch manchmal zu ähnlichen Themen, die auch zu anderen Ergebnissen kommen können. Aber was uns interessiert ist eigentlich, wie sieht die Hochschule auch in 5 oder 10 Jahren aus und da hat natürlich die Hochschulleitung schon einen gewaltigen Einfluss, um festzulegen, was sind eigentlich die Profile meiner Hochschule, was sollen Forschungsschwerpunkte sein, was sollen Kooperationsschwerpunkte sein? Das sind so die Themen, die uns interessieren, deswegen befragen wir eben Direktoren und Präsidenten und jetzt nicht alle Mitglieder einer Hochschule. Und wir suchen uns immer bestimmte Schwerpunktthemen aus.
Diese Jahr ging es um Internationalisierung, letztes Jahr um die Kooperation von Hochschulen mit der Wirtschaft, wir haben uns auch mit der Finanzierungsfragen einmal beschäftigt, mit den Hochschulprofilen allgemein. Und grundsätzlich ist es eine Art Stimmungsindikator, also es gibt ja beispielsweise in der Wirtschaft den IFO-Index, der immer so misst, wie ist denn gerade so die Stimmung? Investiert ihr mehr oder wollt ihr mehr investieren in Zukunft? Oder wollt ihr eher Beschäftigung abbauen?
Die Glaskugel.
Die Glaskugel richtig. Und so etwas in der Art wollten wir auch für das Hochschulsystem aufbauen. Haben deswegen auch so ein Set von Indikatoren, die wir zusammenfassen zum sogenannten Stifterverbands-Index. Um so ja eine Stimmungslage der Hochschulen in Deutschland zu messen.
Und wird das auch schon so wahrgenommen?
Das wird so wahrgenommen. Also vor allem dann natürlich auch in den Einzelergebnissen wird das jeweils wahrgenommen. Gerade im letzten Jahr, als es um die Kooperation mit Unternehmen ging, zwischen Hochschulen und der Wirtschaft, haben wir eigentlich irgendwie ein paar ganz interessante Ergebnisse herausgefunden, die so der allgemeinen Stimmung oder der Wahrnehmung auch widersprochen haben. Denn die Hochschulen wollen eigentlich sehr gerne kooperieren. Nur irgendwie 93% der Hochschulleiter haben gesagt, sie wollen eigentlich mehr mit Unternehmen zusammen forschen. Und das war gerade in so einer öffentlichen Debatte, die das sehr kritisch beleuchtet hat und da wurden die Ergebnisse dann auch seitens der Politik, der Minister wahrgenommen und auch rezipiert.
Wie geht man denn da vor, um solche Antworten dann zu bekommen und auch wirklich halbwegs wissenschaftlich auswerten zu können? Also Sie sagten ja, man befragt die Hochschulleiter im Prinzip, also die reine Leitungsebene, nicht die Wissenschaftler, kriegt der da dann einfach ein Formular zugeschickt, und das füllen die aus und das war es?
Genau. Im Grunde ist es so einfach. Also wir haben unseren Fragebogen, den wir gemeinsam entwickeln. Wir arbeiten an der Stelle in der Tat wissenschaftlich. Haben auch Wissenschaftler, die uns dabei beraten und werten das ganze auch solide statistisch aus. Das ist also insofern da glaube ich schon eine Arbeit, oder die Ergebnisse, die auch belastbar sind.
Könnte mir vorstellen, dass das so durchaus seine Schwierigkeiten hat, da so den richtigen einerseits den richtigen Ton zu treffen, aber was ich meine ist, einfach die richtige Gewichtung da reinzubringen. Weil wenn man das jetzt auswerten will, muss man dem ganzen ja auch einen Wert beimessen und irgendwie versuchen, das Ganze irgendwie auf Zahlen runterzubrechen. Aber das was man erfragt sind ja eigentlich gar keine Zahlen, das sind ja mehr Gefühlslagen oder?
Es sind zu einem ganz großen Teil Gefühlslagen, die wir erfragen. Es gibt auch quantitative Fragen, die wir stellen. Wenn es zum Beispiel um das Volumen an Drittmitteln geht, die aus der Wirtschaft kommen oder die Beträge, die die Hochschulen für Internationalisierung ausgeben. Also manchmal sind auch quantitative Fragen tatsächlich drin. Wir haben den Eindruck, dass das ganz gut funktioniert. Ich glaube, dass uns da auch entgegenkommt, dass wir als Stifterverband in der Hochschullandschaft ganz gut bekannt sind.
Das heißt man hat auch den entsprechenden Rücklauf?
Man hat den entsprechenden Rücklauf und das ist natürlich dann schon wichtig. Also wir liegen bei knapp der Hälfte der Hochschulen, die uns antworten. Bei den großen Hochschulen sind es deutlich mehr. Aber es gibt natürlich, es gibt rund 400 Hochschulen in Deutschland. Davon kennt man vielleicht irgendwie ein Viertel wirklich. Das andere sind kleinere, vor allem private Hochschulen auch, die natürlich auch nicht alle die Kapazität haben, da jetzt 12 Seiten Fragebogen zu beantworten. Aber insgesamt ist es recht repräsentativ, also wir haben auch viele kleinere, die schon mitmachen Gott sei dank. Und die Hochschulen insgesamt decken ungefähr 2/3 aller Studierenden ab. Also Hälfte der Hochschulen antwortet, 2/3 der Studierenden, sind halt schon eher die größeren. Aber die sind natürlich auch für die Stimmungslage insgesamt diejenigen, die die wichtigere Rolle spielen.
Wie ist denn die Stimmung?
Die Stimmung ist besser als der Ruf würde ich sagen. Wir haben schon gemerkt, dass es in den ersten Jahren eher bergab ging. Also 2011 hatten wir die Befragung gestartet. Und wir haben da so einen Indix, der im positiven und im negativen Bereich landen kann. Und um mal eine Zahl zu nennen, also es geht von -100 bis 100 die Skala und wir lagen am Anfang so ungefähr bei 25 Punkten, also so im positiven Bereich auf jeden Fall, aber jetzt keine Jubelstimmung würde ich sagen. Das ging dann schon ein Stück weit zurück in den letzten Jahren und dieses Jahr haben wir das erste Mal konnten wir beobachten, dass sich die Stimmungslage insgesamt wieder verbessert hat.
Also es sank nur unter 25 oder es ging in den negativen Bereich?
Es ging nicht ganz in den negativen Bereich. In einzelnen Teilindikatoren aber schon. Also besonders kritisch ist Finanzierung, Personalsituation, da ist es tatsächlich auch in den negativen Bereich gerutscht.
Was ist denn dann die 0?
Die 0 ist neutrale Stimmung.
Nichts ändert sich sozusagen?
Na wir haben Lageindikatoren und Zukunftsindikatoren. Bei den Lageindikatoren fragen wir immer, wie ist die Lage? Gut, eher gut, neutral, eher schlecht, schlecht. Die 0 ist dann neutral. Also mir geht es jetzt nicht gut, und mir geht es nicht schlecht. Und wenn ich natürlich in die Zukunft gucke die gleiche Skala mit es wird besser, es verändert sich nicht oder es wird schlechter.
Und jetzt sind wir wo?
Jetzt sind wir letztendlich wieder auf dem Startniveau angekommen.
Also 25.
Ja genau, wo wir 2011 auch gestartet sind.
Ist ja für Deutschland schon eine geradezu euphorische Stimmung.
Jaja. Jaja. Wobei also die Zahl verdeckt natürlich, dass das Hochschulsystem schon sehr unterschiedlich ist. Also die privaten Hochschulen die sind wirklich euphorisch. Also da liegen wir bei Werten über 50 im Schnitt. Bei den staatlichen großen Hochschulen kommen wir gerade über die 0-Linie. Also da ist schon eine ganz schöne Streuung im System drin.
Was macht die einen so euphorisch und die anderen so zurückhaltend?
Naja die privaten haben natürlich auch ein paar mehr Freiheiten als es die staatlichen haben. Auch wenn man hört, es gibt je etliche private Hochschulen, die auch an ihre finanziellen Grenzen kommen, die schließen müssen. Also es ist nicht alles rosig im privaten Hochschulsektor. Aber ich glaube einfach, dieses Setting, dass man auch selber entscheiden kann, sein Profil selber gestalten kann, Dinge voranbringen, das sind ein bisschen mehr so die optimistischen Macher. Ich glaube, man muss auch ein optimistischer Macher sein, um an einer privaten Hochschule etwas bewegen zu können. Also es ist sicherlich auch eine andere Kultur, die dort vorherrscht. Und bei den staatlichen, da merkt man schon sehr stark, dass so diese Rahmenbedingungen die Stimmung drücken. Ich hatte ja gerade schon angesprochen, die Finanzierung ist da immer ein ganz großes Thema.
Was sicherlich auch erklärt, warum die Hochschulen, die jetzt in der Exzellenzinitiative beispielsweise erfolgreich waren, die Stimmung auch deutlich besser einschätzen, als das diejenigen tun, die dort keine zusätzlichen Mittel generieren konnten.
Aber ich meine, der Index ist ja im Prinzip relativ zur eigenen Situation. Da müsste ja im Prinzip der Grundoptimismus der Privaten schon eingepreist sein. Auch wenn die sozusagen optimistisch in die Zukunft blicken, dann ja auf Basis ihrer normalen Realität. Von daher scheinen sie ja doch schon deutlich mehr Perspektive für sich zu sehen als es die traditionellen Universitäten machen?
Ja, weil also der private Hochschulsektor hat natürlich in den letzten Jahren auch zugelegt. Also es sind immer mehr private Hochschulen entstanden, es gibt mehr Studierende an den privaten Hochschulen, trotzdem ist es natürlich im Grunde eine Nische, die da besteht.
Ja was ist so der Anteil von Privaten zu nicht Privaten? Kann man das irgendwie mal quantifizieren, so in der Größenordnung von Studierenden?
Also das liegt eher im einstelligen Prozentbereich noch. Die Zahl der Hochschulen ist dafür relativ groß. Aber es sind in der Regel eher kleinere.
Aber hat es dann sozusagen, wird es dann auch in dem Index dann so gewichtet, dass der Stifterverband-Index dann sozusagen auch nur, also dass sie die Meinung der Privaten dann auch nur zu einem Prozent durchschlägt?
Nein wir nehmen da jede Hochschule gleich gewichtet.
Für sich? Okay. Also nicht nach Anzahl der Studierenden?
Nein wir gewichten nicht nach Anzahl der Studierenden, hatten wir auch überlegt, aber wir wollten eigentlich so das Stimmungsbild derjenigen die das ganze treiben, abbilden.
Okay. Ja das bringt uns dann einfach mal so auch zur übergeordneten Ebene. Das eine oder andere ist ja jetzt auch schon angeklungen. Ich denke, die Frage, wo kommen die Gelder her, wo gehen die Gelder hin und wo sollten sie vielleicht besser hingehen oder wo müsste noch etwas hingehen beschäftigt viele, nicht nur die Institutionen, nicht nur die Universitäten selber, sondern eben auch runter bis zu den arbeitenden Wissenschaftlern und natürlich auch den Studierenden, die im Prinzip noch ganz am Anfang ihres Weges sind. Um das mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen, würde ich ganz gerne mal so ganz oben auf die höchstmögliche Ebene gehen. Wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, wo kommen Gelder überhaupt her, die in das universitäre, überhaupt ins Bildungssystem fließen, die also konkret dann auch letztlich Wissenschaft finanzieren? Wer sind sozusagen die wichtigsten Akteure? Wo entstehen Geldströme in Deutschland?
Also im Grunde müsste man auch nochmal unterscheiden zwischen Bildung und Wissenschaft.
Habe ich auch gerade gemerkt.
Ja. Also Bildung ist natürlich der noch etwas größere Bereich insgesamt. Wenn man irgendwie die Ausgaben für alle Schulen zusammen rechnet, dann kommt man auf …
Aber wir wollen ja jetzt schon eigentlich den Fokus auf Wissenschaft legen.
Ja genau. Also um das nochmal in Relation zu setzen, es gibt ja das Ziel der Bundesregierung, 10% des BiPs sollen für Bildung und Wissenschaft ausgegeben werden. Haben wir noch nicht ganz erreicht, aber liegen wir bei irgendwie gut 9% immerhin. Und davon würden gut 2/3 eigentlich im Bildungsbereich landen und 1/3 in der Wissenschaft. Sozusagen da schon mal diese grobe Relation zu haben.
Also 3% des Bruttoinlandproduktes landen staatlicherseits im Wissenschaftssystem?
Das ist nicht nur Staat, sondern Staat und Private, alle zusammen^genommen. Also sollen ungefähr 3% für Forschung und Wissenschaft ausgegeben werden und der Rest für Bildung oder der größere Teil für Bildung. Und wenn man sich den Wissenschaftsbereich dann nochmal getrennt anschaut, dann ist insgesamt so ungefähr pari pari die Finanzierung. Also die Hälfte der Staat, oder knappe Hälfte der Staat, gute Hälfte der private Bereich, insbesondere die Wirtschaft. Und gut im Grunde kann man natürlich sagen, finanzieren wir als Bürger und Bürgerinnen alle natürlich das Wissenschaftssystem. Also entweder als Steuerzahler oder als Konsument. Aber wenn man das mal nach den Sektoren sich anschaut, dann ist natürlich die Wirtschaft sehr stark auch in der Finanzierung, vor allem der Forschung und Entwicklung.
Weil Wissenschaft kann man dann auch nochmal ein bisschen weiter runter brechen und sagen, das eine sind wirklich so die konkreten Aktivitäten, die Produkte generieren sollen, neue Dienstleistungen, innovativ oder für den Bereich der Innovation, also alles was Forschung und Entwicklung im groben betrifft. Und da kommen 2/3 der Ausgaben wiederum von den Unternehmen und 1/3 vom Staat. Der Staat finanziert aber überwiegend den Teil der wissenschaftlichen Ausbildung, den man natürlich zur Wissenschaft dann auch nochmal dazurechnen kann. Also insgesamt sind es in Deutschland ungefähr ungefähr 100 Milliarden, die wir für Wissenschaft ausgeben und Unternehmen geben …
Also das sind sozusagen diese 3% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts.
Ja genau, beziehungsweise gut 3% sind das dann. Und wenn man das auf Forschung dann runterbricht, dann sind es ungefähr 70-80 Milliarden und davon trägt die Wirtschaft wie gesagt 2/3, das sind dann gute 50 Milliarden. Viele Zahlen gerade, ich hoffe, das ist noch nachvollziehbar.
Ja na gut, es geht ja vor allem um die Größenordnungen, die haben wir ja hier auch mit drin. Und auch natürlich die Anteile. Wenn man da jetzt mal kurz bei bleibt, wenn wir sagen, die Wirtschaft zahlt das, in welcher Form zahlt die Wirtschaft das? Also ich meine, auf der einen Seite haben natürlich besondere große Unternehmen natürlich auch eigene Forschungsabteilungen, beschäftigen sehr viele Wissenschaftler, das schließt das jetzt auch mit ein. Aber eben nicht nur oder?
Nicht nur. Aber es ist schon der ganz überwiegende Teil. Also es gibt den Bereich der internen F&E, also Forschung und Entwicklung, das ist schon der Löwenanteil. Aber die Unternehmen geben auch einen Teil der Forschungsaufträge nach draußen, entweder ins Ausland, dieser Anteil nimmt immer mehr zu. Oder an staatliche Forschungseinrichtungen auch in Deutschland. An Hochschulen, an außeruniversitäre Forschungseinrichtungen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht wenig, das ist gerade für den Hochschulbereich auch eine relevante Größe. Für das Gesamtvolumen, was die Unternehmen ausgeben ist es aber eher ein kleinerer Teil.
Ist das eher ein Trend, der verschwindet oder ist das etwas, was wächst?
Es wächst, aber es wächst unterproportional. Also die Unternehmen geben zwar mehr Geld auch an Hochschulen und außeruniversitäre Einrichtungen für die Forschung, aber sie geben noch mehr Geld eigentlich in Forschung, die sie im Ausland unternehmen beispielsweise. Also so dieser Eindruck, dass …
Also im Ausland dann auch an universitäre Einrichtungen oder Ausland nur im Sinne von, es landet nicht in Deutschland und dann wird es bei anderen Unternehmen geparkt?
Also es landet nicht in Deutschland. Wo es dann im Ausland genau landet, das ist nicht so einfach nachzuvollziehen. Es geht natürlich dort auch an wissenschaftliche Einrichtungen, gerade wenn dort besondere Kompetenzen bestehen im Bio-Tech-Bereich, es gibt ja viele Bereiche, wo Deutschland in der Forschung vielleicht auch nicht 1a aufgestellt ist.
Sprich das ist eigentlich mehr der Trend hin zu einer Internationalisierung auch der Forschung und der Verflechtung der Wirtschaft an der Stelle?
Absolut.
Also würde man da auch im Umkehrschluss erwarten, dass natürlich auch die Wirtschaft in anderen Ländern genauso auch Aufträge nach Deutschland reinbringt, so dass sich das an der Stelle vielleicht wieder ausgleicht?
So ist das auch genau. Also es gibt auch mehr ausländische Unternehmen, die in Deutschland irgendwie Forschung betreiben. Aber die Datenbasis ist da nicht ganz so gut, um das wirklich nachvollziehen zu können, ist es ein Ausgleich oder verlieren wir jetzt netto?
Aber findet schon auf jeden Fall statt?
Es findet statt, es geht in beide Richtungen. In der Tat ist es natürlich der Trend, Wissenschaft auch zu internationalisieren.
Wenn man sich jetzt nochmal den staatlichen Anteil anschaut, Sie sagten ja, der Staat unterstützt vor allem die Ausbildung. Das ist ja klar, also vor allem natürlich in der Form der universitären oder sprachen Sie jetzt konkret über wissenschaftliche Ausbildung?
Es ging jetzt da um wissenschaftliche Ausbildung, also ums Studium, um es ganz platt zu sagen. Genau. Und das ist natürlich der Bereich, wo der Staat den ganz großen Anteil der Kosten auch übernimmt. Die Privaten sind in Deutschland ja relativ befreit davon, da irgendeinen eigenen Beitrag leisten zu müssen. Also Stichwort Studiengebühren, das sieht in anderen Ländern natürlich ganz anders aus. Hier sind es insbesondere natürlich die Länder, die über die Grundfinanzierung der Hochschulen die wissenschaftliche Ausbildung in Deutschland finanzieren.
Das ist ja jetzt ein bisschen verwirrend auch, weil eigentlich Bildung ist Ländersache, trotz alledem gibt es natürlich auch ein bundesstaatliches Engagement, was ja auch gerade zuletzt stark in der Debatte stand durch die Exzellenzinitiative. Wie geht das jetzt zusammen, wie sind da jetzt so die Trends? Also haben wir starke Unterschiede in den einzelnen Ländern, wie sehr Wissenschaft an der Stelle auch gewichtet wird, gleicht sich das im wesentlichen aus und welche Rolle hat der Bund da bisher gespielt und wie ändert sich das unter Umständen gerade?
Also wir können eigentlich so seit 10 Jahren beobachten, dass es dort Veränderungen gibt. Die Länder haben lange Zeit ihre Finanzierung nicht so stark ausgebaut, wie sie es eigentlich hätten ausbauen müssen. Was ja auch seit mehreren Jahren zu beobachten ist, dass ja die Neigung zu studieren zugenommen hat. Also wir haben die höchsten Studienanfängerzahlen seit immer. Und die Finanzierung der Hochschulen ist nicht in dem gleichen Maße gewachsen. Also gerade von Länderseite. Also im Grunde sind die Grundmittel, die die Länder den Hochschulen zur Verfügung stellen, über die Jahre konstant geblieben, wenn man jetzt noch Inflation usw. rausrechnet. Wenn man berücksichtigt, dass die Zahl der Studierenden natürlich deutlich zugenommen hat, ist die Finanzierung anteilig sogar rückläufig gewesen.
Hat denn auch die Zeit, die studiert wird, zugenommen? Also ich meine durch diese Reform, den Bologna-Prozess, also die Aufteilung in Bachelor und Master, könnte man jetzt erst mal denken, viele studieren zwar mehr, aber sie studieren weniger, weil sie eigentlich nur durch die Bachelor-Zeit gehen oder ist das eine Fehlwahrnehmung?
Ja es gibt natürlich einen überwiegenden Teil der Studierenden, die auch den Master noch anschließen wollen und tun.
Ja. Also wirklich abgenommen hat die Studienzeit in dem Sinne nicht. Die Bologna-Reform hat ja zum Ziel auch, dass die erwarteten Studienzeiten, die Regelstudienzeiten auch besser eingehalten werden können, indem man das ganze etwas besser strukturiert und modularisiert und da nicht so die große Diskrepanz ist, dass es eigentlich eine Regelstudienzeit von 9 Semestern gibt, aber die durchschnittliche Studienzeit irgendwie 12 oder 13 Semester ist. Das war ja früher einfach so. Also Regelstudienzeit war ja eine unrealistische Vorgabe. Die haben die wenigsten eingehalten. Vielleicht die, die sich es nur nicht anders leisten konnten.
Der überwiegende?
Ist das jetzt anders?
Das hat sich schon deutlich angeglichen, ja. Also die Regelstudienzeiten im Bachelor sind schon deutlich näher an den tatsächlichen Studienzeiten auch mit dran und beim Master auch.
Also insofern schon eine Verkürzung der Zeit pro Student, aber trotzdem viele neue Studenten und von daher insgesamt immer noch mehr Zeit, die an Universitäten verbracht wird und die entsprechend finanziert werden muss?
Genau, so ist das.
Und da ist dann die Finanzierung bei den Ländern nicht mitgezogen über die Zeit in demselben Maße? Ist das im wesentlichen bei allen Ländern so oder gibt es da große Unterschiede?
Da gibt es schon sehr große Unterschiede. Die sind natürlich auch von unterschiedlichem Niveau gestartet. Also eher unterproportional, der Anstieg ist zum Beispiel in den ostdeutschen Bundesländern gewesen. Da sind natürlich auch die Studierendenzahlen nicht so stark gestiegen, wie im Rest der Republik demografisch bedingt. Aber da waren die Wachstumszahlen besonders niedrig. Es gibt auch einzelne Bundesländer, die eher gekürzt haben, auch insbesondere die Stadtstaaten Bremen, Berlin auch, was natürlich daran lag, dass sie im Vergleich zu vielen Flächenländern insgesamt immer schon sehr viel ausgegeben haben für ihre Hochschulen. Und sie haben natürlich eine Ausgabe, die eigentlich über die Ausbildung der Landeskinder hinausgeht. In Berlin studieren natürlich viele, die auch nicht aus Berlin kommen. Das heißt Berlin nimmt da eine Aufgabe war, die eigentlich von bundesweiter Bedeutung ist, die aber über den Landeshaushalt in Berlin finanziert wird.
Da gibt es natürlich auch ein gewisses Ungleichgewicht. Und Berlin ist ja auch nicht auf Rosen gebettet, insofern nachvollziehbar, dass man auch guckt, dass das Ganze wieder in ein anderes Verhältnis kommt. Aber wenn man das natürlich aus gesamtstaatlicher Perspektive sieht, dann sind solche Entwicklungen natürlich nicht wünschenswert. Das Sozialsystem da insgesamt an der kurzen Leine gehalten wird. Es gibt auch andere Beispiele. Einige süddeutsche Länder, Hessen beispielsweise, haben schon ihre Volumina deutlich nach oben geschoben. Aber in der Summe gesehen eher ein mäßiger Aufwuchs, der dazu führt, dass pro Studierendem sogar weniger Geld zur Verfügung steht als Jahre zuvor.
Ich meine, das Klagelied hört man aus der Wissenschaft, wenn man mit Professoren und Hochschulleitern spricht immer wieder. Wird denn das in der Politik auch entsprechend wahrgenommen?
Die Wahrnehmung ist sicherlich da. Die finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen, Haushaltsbedingungen sind natürlich eine andere Geschichte. Da sorgt natürlich auch die Vorgabe, ausgeglichene Haushalte zu erreichen, nicht dafür, dass man da jetzt mit dem Geld um sich wirft in dem Bereich. Und es ist natürlich einer der großen Ausgabenposten in den Ländern. Also das ist ein Teil, wo man auch noch substanziell Gelder bewegen kann in die eine oder andere Richtung. Aber das war sicherlich auch mit ein Anlass dafür, dass der Bund gesagt hat, gut es ist ein gesamtstaatliches Interesse, dass die Hochschulen funktionieren, und der hat da insbesondere eigentlich seit 2006 die Ausgaben für die Hochschulen, für Wissenschaft insgesamt, aber auch für die Hochschulen massiv nach oben gefahren.
Also welchen konkreten Anteil übt denn dann der Bund eigentlich aus, wenn es eigentlich erst mal Ländersache ist?
Also es ist noch auch der deutlich kleinere Teil. So ungefähr 90:10 ist das dann.
Na gut, aber rein rechtlich, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es denn dann, wenn Bildung jetzt erst mal auf Ländersache ist, dann ist es ja erst mal kein Posten für den Bund, der einfach so ins Buch geschrieben ist, welche Wege nimmt das Bundesgeld, um letzten Endes im Bildungs- und Wissenschaftssystem zu landen auf Länderebene?
Das sind ganz viele gemeinsame Projekte auch, dass nicht der Bund etwas alleine finanziert, sondern er finanziert etwas zusammen mit dem Ländern. Exzellenzinitiative ist so ein Beispiel, der Hochschulpakt ist ein anderes Beispiel. Da hat sich die Situation natürlich ein bisschen geändert. Wir haben jetzt einen neuen Paragraph 99b im Grundgesetz, der also die Möglichkeit gemeinsamen Handelns von Bund und Ländern im Wissenschaftsbereich erleichtert. Das sieht man auch.
Paragraph in welchem Gesetz?
Im Grundgesetz.
Ah ja.
Das sogenannte Kooperationsverbot, was immer diskutiert wurde auch, dass es fallen muss und dass das jetzt die Möglichkeit auch schafft, dass der Bund stärker im Hochschulbereich finanziert. Er hatte die Möglichkeit auch vorher, aber in einem eingeschränkteren Maße, es ging vor allem darum, dass er nur temporär letztendlich agieren kann. Und deswegen sind diese ganzen Programme auch nur auf Zeit und in der Regel als Drittmittel und keine Grundfinanzierung für das Hochschulsystem.
Vielleicht beleuchten wir mal gerade diese beiden Dinge. Also die Exzellenzinitiative hat ja auch einen extremen öffentlichkeitswirksamen Effekt gehabt, unabhängig davon, ob der jetzt so beabsichtigt war oder nicht, aber da wurde viel drüber diskutiert, es hatte eine extreme Wahrnehmung, gepaart also abgesehen von, da kommt jetzt viel Geld, war natürlich auch so die Frage, okay ist es überhaupt der richtige Ansatz, jetzt einzelne Universitäten zu fördern, die ohnehin schon gut dastehen, weil genau damit bewerben sie sich ja im Prinzip für diesen Pool. Wie ist diese Debatte verlaufen? Wie sehen Sie das auch selber? Welche Effekte lassen sich denn jetzt nach der kurzen Zeit vielleicht sogar schon ablesen?
Die Effekte werden ja gerade evaluiert. Also um das sozusagen nochmal auf eine wissenschaftliche Basis zu stehen. Der Blick ist glaube ich manchmal ein bisschen verkürzt, weil die Exzellenzinitiative ja drei Programmlinien hatte. Das sind auf der einen Seite Graduiertenschulen, auf der anderen Seite Exzellenzcluster. Und das Dritte sind die sogenannten Zukunftskonzepte gewesen und das ist in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung immer das präsente. Das sind dann im Grunde diese Elitehochschulen diese 11, die so ein bisschen herausstechen. Aber es geht eben nicht nur um diese wenigen ausgewählten Hochschulen, sondern es geht um eine breitere Finanzierung insgesamt von Forschungsexzellenz in Deutschland. Und es profitieren also schon deutlich mehr Hochschulen eigentlich von der Exzellenzinitiative als man gemeinhin denkt.
Okay, also ein Wahrnehmungsproblem an der Stelle?
Es ist ein gewisses Wahrnehmungsproblem, aber natürlich ist es trotzdem eine Zweiteilung des Systems. Also es gibt die einen, die profitieren und die anderen, die nicht profitieren. Und man merkt ja auch an der Stimmung an den Hochschulen, dass es da zu Unterschieden geführt hat. Nun war ja so der Anlass auch, dass man gesagt hat, naja man braucht auch eine gewissen internationale Wahrnehmung des Hochschulsystems in Deutschland und wenn wir in der Breite gut sind, dann ist das wichtig, aber wenn wir auch international wettbewerbsfähig sein wollen, dann brauchen wir auch Hochschulen oder Forschungsbereiche mit einer internationalen Strahlkraft. Und ich glaube der Mobilisierungseffekt der Exzellenzinitiative war schon enorm. Man darf ja im Grunde nicht nur auf die gucken, die am Ende profitieren, sondern man muss ja eigentlich auf alle gucken, die daran teilgenommen haben.
Und die Hochschulen sind so auch gezwungen worden, sich einfach mal über sich selbst bewusst zu werden, ihre eigenen Stärken und Schwächen zu reflektieren, ihr Profil zu reflektieren, bin ich eigentlich auf dem richtigen Weg, wo liegt meine Chance im Wissenschaftsbereich, soll ich mich in der Breite aufstellen oder habe ich nicht noch einzelne Fachbereiche, die besonders gut sind, die ich auch noch weiter stärken möchte? Also auch viele Hochschulen, die jetzt am Ende vielleicht gar nicht finanziell profitieren, haben sich allein dadurch, dass sie sich mal auf den Weg gemacht haben, sicherlich auch in ihrer Struktur, in ihrem Denken nochmal neu aufgestellt, das ist auch ein positiver Effekt, der von der ganzen Initiative mit ausgeht.
Der Zug ist ja auch nicht abgefahren. Also die zweite Tranche steht jetzt glaube ich bald an oder?
Die dritte schon.
Die dritte.
Geht jetzt in die dritte Runde. Da wird es sicher auch Modifizierungen geben. Das ist ja auch politisch debattiert. Es gibt auch unterschiedliche Positionen, also wie stark eigentlich so dieser Elitegedanke noch eine Rolle spielen soll oder ob andere Themen, beispielsweise der Kooperation in der Region oder mit anderen Einrichtungen, Wissenschaftseinrichtungen, Unternehmen außerhalb der Hochschule, ob das nicht auch viel stärker Berücksichtigung finden soll.
Also Sie würden sagen, das hat jetzt insgesamt erst mal eine positive Auswirkung gehabt? Und wenn es sozusagen nur ist, um bestimmte Universitäten überhaupt erst mal in so einen Wettbewerbsmodus zu bringen, der zur Überdenkung der eigenen Situation beigetragen hat?
Das hat auf jeden Fall da einen positiven Effekt gehabt und man muss ja auch sehen, dass die Exzellenzinitiative nicht das einzige Programm ist, was Bund und Länder gemeinsam für die Hochschulen gemacht haben. Also finanziell deutlich wichtiger ist beispielsweise der Hochschulpakt. Da geht es darum, ja auch die steigenden Studierendenzahlen ein Stück weit finanziell abzufedern. Das ist in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung jetzt nicht so präsent. Auch der Qualitätspakt Lehre ist nicht so präsent. Der Qualitätspakt Lehre beispielsweise profitiert knapp 200 Hochschulen. Das verteilt sich natürlich dann mehr das Geld, was da zur Verfügung steht, aber da hat man diese Breitenförderung, die man vielleicht in der Exzellenzinitiative an der einen oder anderen Stelle vermisst hat.
Und all diese ganzen Initiativen, Exzellenzinitiative, Hochschulpakt etc. sind immer über diesen dualen Ansatz, über der Bund fördert gemeinsam mit dem Land einen bestimmten Aspekt abgelaufen?
Also das ist kompliziert. Die Anteile, die der Bund trägt und die Länder tragen, das variiert unglaublich zwischen den einzelnen Programmen und Projekten. In der Exzellenzinitiative ist es beispielsweise so, dass 50% der Bund trägt, 50% die Länder.
Jetzt hatten wir grundsätzlich, um das nochmal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, also wir versuchen ja immer noch so ein bisschen, die Finanzfläche überhaupt erst mal zu lokalisieren. Also 3% des BiPs, des Bruttoinlandsprodukts, nicht Bundesbruttoinlandsproduktes, jetzt habe ich es wieder, überhaupt fließt sozusagen in die Wissenschaft, großen Anteil trägt der Staat vor allem eben zur Förderung der Forschungseinrichtung. Und abgesehen von dem traditionellen breiten Verteilen von Bildung in der Gesellschaft, was ja markanter Aspekt unseres Wissenschaftssystems überhaupt ist, und Bildungssystems überhaupt ist, dass man versucht, Bildung möglichst in die Breite zu tragen, gibt es in letzter Zeit in zunehmendem Maße diesen Fokus, dass man eben auch gezielter fördert, ich will jetzt nicht das Wort Elite nehmen, aber sozusagen ambitioniertere Projekte nochmal konkret zu unterstützen und dort geht auch der Bund selber sehr viel mehr noch in die Leistungen mit rein, weil das einfach so die Länder in der Form hätten gar nicht lostreten können?
Ja.
Und das ist sozusagen ein Prozess, der jetzt läuft. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Wirtschaft, die vor allem im Bereich Forschung und Entwicklung einen Großteil stemmt, primär über eigene Institute, über selbstbeschäftigte Wissenschaftler, teilweise eben auch über externe Aufträge. Jetzt gibt es ja noch diesen zweiten Teil, der ja auch den Stifterverband konkret betrifft. Gelder, die über Stiftungen in das System fließen. Welchen Anteil hat das am Gesamtsystem?
Der finanzielle Beitrag ist vergleichsweise bescheiden, muss man sagen, also da sind schon Staat und Wirtschaft die Hauptakteure. Ich glaube aber, den Gesamteffekt den darf man nicht unterschätzen. Weil private Initiativen, Stiftungen, natürlich oft viel flexibler agieren können, als dass der Staat kann. Und sie haben eigentlich eine Impulsfunktion im System. Sie können viel stärker frühzeitig versuchen, Trends zu erkennen, zu verstärken. Sie können in bestimmten Bereichen Schwerpunkte setzen, in bestimmten Forschungsbereichen, wie es der Staat vielleicht nicht kann, weil er natürlich immer auch eine gewisse politische Ausgewogenheit verfolgen muss. Also die Impulsfunktion so der privaten Wissenschaftsförderung, die ist glaube ich groß.
Und wahrscheinlich auch teilweise auch anders als es die Wirtschaft machen kann, weil sie sehr viel produkt- und anwendungs- und marktorientierter denkt, aber vielleicht jetzt nicht so sehr Ziele der Grundlagenforschung unterstützt, wie das teilweise bei einzelnen Stiftungen der Fall ist.
Richtig, also Unternehmen müssen natürlich irgendwie immer im Blick behalten, nützt es mir am Ende auch etwas?
Rechnet sich das.
Rechnet sich das, genau. Also Unternehmen denken dann auch durchaus perspektivisch. Also sie investieren auch viel, auch beispielsweise in Hochschullehre, wo sie jetzt nicht ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr später direkt ein Produkt daraus ableiten können. Sondern sie arbeiten schon daran, dass die Rahmenbedingungen verbessert werden. Wenn ich jetzt in Hochschullehre investiere denke ich, dass ich später bessere Mitarbeiter bekomme, aber ich habe jetzt nicht unmittelbar den Nutzen. Also es gibt auch durchaus perspektivische Investitionen von Unternehmen oder sie fördern auch über Stiftungen letztendlich auch die Grundlagenforschung. Aber klar ist, dass der private Wissenschaftsförderer, also Stiftungen dann noch ein ganzes Stück weit freier sind. Und da finden die Investitionen statt auch in Projekte, wo der direkte Nutzen vielleicht auch noch gar nicht erkennbar ist oder erst in späteren Schleifen entsteht.
Ja wenn ich jetzt Grundlagen entwickele und da muss ich dann in 10-20 Jahren entstehen da vielleicht dann konkrete Dinge daraus, aber natürlich muss ich diese Grundlagen erst mal schaffen, um später auch Anwendungsmöglichkeiten zu finden.
Ja teilweise kann man ja auch gar nicht wissen, was dabei rauskommt, ich denke das ist so ein Wesen der Grundlagenforschung, dass man ja erst mal an den Grundlagen forscht und dann später feststellt, ah so sind die Grundlagen, dann ergibt sich ja jetzt auf einmal diese Möglichkeit, aber da kann man ja gar nicht drauf hin planen.
Man kann nicht drauf hin planen, aber man kann natürlich schon ein System auch entwickeln, in dem vielleicht nicht unbedingt der Forscher, der an einer Grundlagenforschung arbeitet, sich konkrete Gedanken machen muss, wie es in die Anwendung geht, aber indem es schon auch Institutionen, Personen gibt, die sich genau damit beschäftigen. So dass man immer so ein bisschen auch im Blick behält die Grundlagenforschung, was kommt da eigentlich raus, in welche Richtung geht das, welche Anwendungsfelder können sich da irgendwann auftun? Damit nicht irgendwie so eine große Lücke entsteht, wo man dann irgendwie 20 Jahre später feststellt, ach da hätte ich ja was draus machen können. Also dieser Verwertungsprozess den kann man natürlich auch schon ein Stück weit managen, ohne dass man gleich verlangt, dass eine Grundlagenforschung Anwendungsbezug haben muss.
Wo wir schon bei den Stiftungen sind, vielleicht noch mal ein paar Worte zu dem Engagement und auch dem finanziellen Engagement, was jetzt vom Stifterverband durchgeführt und begleitet wird. Also auch der Stifterverband bezieht ja sein Geld vor allem aus der Wirtschaft, die im Stifterverband Mitglied sind. Welche Richtung wird das investiert und ausgeschüttet?
Also der Stifterverband hat da letztendlich zwei Säulen. Wir betreuen eine Vielzahl von Stiftungen, die selber wissenschaftsfördernd arbeiten und der Stifterverband arbeitet selbstprogrammatisch. Die Programmatik des Stifterverbandes liegt allerdings nicht in der direkten Forschungsförderung. Da gibt es andere Stiftungen, Volkswagenstiftung, Thyssen-Krupp-Stiftung, die direkte Forschungsprojekte fördern. Das machen wir als Kernbereich Stifterverband nicht, sondern unsere Förderungen gehen eigentlich eher in das große Ganze. Also wir versuchen, die Rahmenbedingungen an den Hochschulen ein Stück weit zu verbessern, dass dann am Ende natürlich auch die Forschung davon profitiert, die Lehre davon profitiert, aber jetzt nicht das Forschungsprojekt zur Batterieforschung oder zur Energieforschung oder Gesundheitsforschung, sondern eher, dass die Hochschuhen funktionsfähig bleiben und vielleicht noch ein bisschen funktionsfähiger werden.
Ja und auch durch die konkrete Betreuung anderer Stiftungen ermöglicht ja sozusagen der Stifterverband die Arbeit der Stiftung, die eben solche Forschungsprojekte dann vorantreiben.
Genau, das ist dann die zweite Säule, da geht es dann auch in die direkte Forschungsförderung oder Individualförderung, Stipendien für Wissenschaftler, da ist das ganze große Portfolio der Wissenschaftsförderung dann auch vorhanden.
Ich will jetzt nochmal einen anderen Punkt aufgreifen, der ja in dieser ganzen Finanzierungsdiskussion auch sehr viel Mindshare hat, der irgendwie immer wieder aufkommt, die Frage dieser Drittmittelförderung, das ist ja etwas, was sich über die letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte, ich weiß gar nicht schleichend, aber auf jeden Fall deutlich ausgeprägt hat, ich glaube noch vor 30 Jahren oder so spielte das im Prinzip keine nennenswerte Rolle, heute ist es schon relevant für die Beschäftigung neuer Professoren, die sich eigentlich von Vornherein darauf einstellen müssen, wenn ich mir hier eine Professur erarbeiten möchte, dann ist das einfach Teil meiner Arbeit. Sprich man muss als Lehrende und Forschende da einfach selber Beziehung aufbauen und für Fördergelder sorgen oder für direkte Finanzierung von Forschungsprojekten, die einem sozusagen der Apparat, in dem man ja eigentlich beschäftigt ist, selber so nicht bereitstellt.
Wie hat sich das so entwickelt? Welche Dimensionen haben diese Drittmittel mittlerweile im Forschungssystem?
Also insbesondere im Hochschulsystem haben sie inzwischen eine wirklich große Bedeutung muss man sagen. Also absolut gesehen sind ungefähr 7 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr Drittmittel an den Hochschulen. Grundmittel so um die 25 Milliarden. Also ein knappes Viertel letztendlich des Hochschulbudgets sind inzwischen Drittmittel. Das war noch vor 10-15 Jahren deutlich weniger. Da waren es irgendwie 10 Prozentpunkte weniger. Da erkennt man in der Tat den Trend von mehr Wettbewerb auch in der Hochschulfinanzierung. Dieser Wettbewerb trifft nicht alle Hochschulen gleichermaßen. Also wenn man sagt, im Durchschnitt sind es 25%, dann gibt es etliche der großen Universitäten, die einen Drittmittelanteil von um die 40% haben.
Also wer natürlich forschungsstark ist, der hat auch einen deutlich höheren Drittmittelanteil. Bei kleineren Hochschulen, Fachhochschulen, die jetzt auch sich weniger im Bereich der Forschung aufstellen, da spielen Drittmittel auch noch eine sehr untergeordnete Rolle. Aber Drittmittel sind ja alles nur die Gelder, die von extern nochmal an die Hochschulen fließen. Wobei extern dann auch relativ zu sehen ist, weil der größte Teil der Drittmittel kommt tatsächlich auch vom Staat.
Der größte Teil?
Der größte Teil der Drittmittel kommt vom Staat.
Ich denke das ist glaube ich keine populäre Wahrnehmung, sondern dass man denkt, Drittmittel heißt vor allem betteln gehen bei privaten Unternehmen. Das ist gar nicht so?
Das ist definitiv nicht so. Also von allen Drittmittelgebern ist die DFG der größte. Mit weit über 2 Milliarden Euro.
Also Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft.
Aber auch der Staat, also die verschiedenen Ministerien mit ihren Ausschreibungen, insbesondere natürlich das Forschungsministerium, aber auch das Wirtschaftsministerium, auch deren Ausgaben sind größer als die Drittmittel der Wirtschaft. Also da ist sicherlich auch irgendwie eine falsche Wahrnehmung oft vorhanden und vor allem die Drittmittel der Wirtschaft sind weniger stark gestiegen als die der öffentlichen Hand. Also wenn man irgendwie sagt, es kommt mehr Wettbewerb  rein,dann ist es eigentlich tatsächlich politisch gewollt und politisch umgesetzt durch die verschiedenen Initiativen, Exzellenzinitiative ist nur ein Beispiel davon, wo dann Drittmittel über die Hochschulen verteilt werden.
Das heißt auch an der Stelle ist das eigentlich eine zusätzliche Förderung des Bundes primär in seiner Unterstützung von DFG und vergleichbaren Institutionen? Wo dann quasi eigentlich die Mittel noch sehr viel mehr an so eine nicht wissenschaftlichen Prozess und eine entsprechende Bewertung gebunden sind? Wo man sagt, okay wir entscheiden das jetzt nicht als Bundesregierung und geben das Geld jetzt für Thema X, sondern wir delegieren das in eine Forschungsgemeinschaft, die kennt sich mit dem Bereich ohnehin besser aus und kann viel besser bewerten, wer jetzt eben wirklich einen legitimen Anspruch auch hat auf so eine Förderung, der dann in Form dieser Drittmittelgeschichte rausgegeben wird. Und der im Prinzip dann quasi von der anderen Seite an der Universität aufschlägt, indem es halt mehr oder weniger direkt bei den Professoren und Professorinnen landet? Ist das eine nachvollziehbare Sichtweise oder?
Ja, also es ist natürlich, dass der Bund hier der Antreiber gewesen ist. Wenn man sich das bei den Hochschulen anguckt, dann sind DFG-Drittmittel, die ja nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien vergeben werden, nach reinen wissenschaftlichen Kriterien, abgesehen von Problemen, die es in jeder Institution gibt, wo es natürlich dann auch gewisse Pfadabhängigkeiten zu beobachten gibt, dann ist das immer ein Kriterium, mit dem der Wissenschaftler auch Reputation gewinnt. Also wenn ich ein DFG-Projekt an Land ziehe, dann ehrt mich das. Dann ist das auch nach verschiedenen Bewertungsskalen, wenn ich dann irgendwie in Berufungsverhandlungen gehe oder Neuberufungen, das ist ein Asset mit dem ich dann wuchern kann. Das ist eine Währung geworden auch im Wissenschaftssystem.
Interessanterweise unterscheiden sich die Drittmittel da auch deutlich. Also die Hochschulen legen da ganz unterschiedliche Kriterien an, wenn sie so leistungsorientierte Mittelvergabe auch belohnen. Dann zählen DFG-Drittmittel in der Bewertung deutlich mehr als Drittmittel, die Wissenschaftler aus der Wirtschaft attrahieren. Also da nehmen die Hochschulen eine Wertung vor und sagen, ja also DFG-Drittmittel find ich gut, wenn ihr das einwerbt, wenn ihr Drittmittel von einem Unternehmen einwerbt finde ich das so mittel.
Warum?
Naja Unternehmens-Drittmittel haben natürlich einen stärkeren Anwendungsbezug, sind auch nicht in rein wissenschaftlichen Kriterien vergeben, und da sagen die Hochschulen, ja das hilft uns vielleicht bei der Finanzierung der Wissenschaft, aber es entspricht eben nicht den wissenschaftlichen Exzellenzkriterien, die wir eigentlich als Hochschule anwenden wollen.
Also rein aus dem Wissenschaftsgedanken. An der Stelle sei auch nochmal auf eine andere Sendung hier von Forschergeist verwiesen, wer das vielleicht noch nicht gehört hat, Ausgabe 13 setzt sich ja intensiv mit dem Horizont2020 oder Horizon2020-Programm der EU auseinander, was ja im Prinzip hier auch nochmal mit rein spielt. Also wie es die nationalen Drittmittel der Forschungsgesellschaften gibt, gibt es ja im vergleichbaren Maße eben EU-Förderprogramme, die eben für spezielle Projekte gegeben werden, vor allem natürlich welche, die sich auch auf europäischer Ebene stark vernetzen. Das ist ja nochmal ein zweiter Aspekt. Aber auch an der Stelle ist es ja vor allem die wissenschaftliche Arbeit, die gefördert wird, unabhängig von der Wirtschaft. Jetzt aber auch so, dass diese Drittmittel, was bezahlen die denn eigentlich?
Und ist es nicht so, dass die Universitäten teilweise dadurch auch noch quasi mehr Arbeit haben? Also werden denn aus diesen Drittmitteln dann auch immer entsprechend die Hochschulen so beglückt? Also freuen die sich jetzt nur, weil der Wissenschaftler für seine wissenschaftliche Arbeit gelobt wird? Oder ist es sozusagen auch für die Hochschule für den Apparat selber ein Gewinn?
Also das ist in der Tat noch ein Problem. Es war früher noch stärker ein Problem. Weil überwiegend die Projektkosten übernommen werden von den Drittmitteln. Das heißt der Wissenschaftler wird finanziert, das Labor wird zumindest anteilig noch finanziert, aber alles andere, was noch in der Hochschule mit dranhängt, der gesamte Overhead, das ist die Diskussion letztendlich um die Finanzierung der Overheads, die Verwaltung, die Infrastruktur, die eine Hochschule insgesamt braucht, die werde noch nicht grundsätzlich erfasst. Also Ziel ist eigentlich auch, so eine Art Vollkostenrechnung bei Forschungsprojekten zu erreichen. Dass ich also wirklich sehe nicht nur, was muss ich jetzt für das konkrete Projekt ausgeben, sondern was hängt auch alles noch mit hinten dran. Aber das ist noch in wenigen Teilen letztendlich wirklich erreicht.
Was gibt es denn da zu erreichen? Also ich meine, der DFG müsste doch diese Problematik zum Beispiel vollkommen klar sein, dass auch so immer administratorische Probleme da dranhängen und könnte man nicht sagen, es gibt hier einen bestimmten Prozentsatz, der wie die Mehrwertsteuer am Ende noch draufgeschlagen wird?
So ist das auch. Also es gibt eine Programmpauschale bei der DFG, die deckt einen Teil der Overheadkosten auf jeden Fall ab. Das sind aber auch immer langwierige politische Diskussionen. Wer zahlt nämlich jetzt diesen Overhead? Inzwischen ist da die Finanzierung beim Bund gelandet. Weil die Länder auch nicht bereit waren, da sich zu engagieren. Ja die Frage ist, reicht das aus? Und dieser Overhead ist natürlich auch von Hochschule zu Hochschule sehr unterschiedlich. Also wenn ich jetzt Hochschulen habe, die eine große Infrastruktur aufgebaut haben, große Labore, teure Labore, dann haben die natürlich ganz andere Overheadkosten als andere. Die Overheadkosten in einem technischen Forschungsprojekt sind wahrscheinlich auch andere als in einem geisteswissenschaftlichen. Also da geht man natürlich dann eher so mit dem Rasenmäher vor und sagt, jeder wird jetzt erst mal gleich behandelt.
Deswegen eigentlich das Ziel Vollkosten auch zu berechnen, wo man dann wirklich auch nachvollziehbar zeigen kann, dieses Projekt, wenn ich das finanzieren möchte, muss ich das und das und das alles berücksichtigen. Aber das ist sozusagen das was der Bund macht. Das BMBF gibt auch solche Programmpauschalen. Bei Drittmitteln aus der Wirtschaft ist das letztendlich individuell verhandelt. Und da haben wir auch mal gesehen in einer Umfrage auch im Rahmen des Hochschulbarometers, dass es da stark auf die Verhandlungsposition auch drauf ankommt. Also die Hochschulen, die auch eine Forschungsexzellenz haben, den fällt es deutlich leichter, bei den Unternehmen auch noch alle Vollkosten abrechnen zu können oder Programmpauschalen einzufordern. Hochschulen, die vielleicht froh sind, wenn sie insgesamt mal ein paar Drittmittel auch an Land ziehen können, die haben da mehr Schwierigkeiten.
Das heißt das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie man auch selber aufgestellt ist und man muss auch ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie man selber quasi da stolz auftreten kann und sagen kann, ja hier hör mal, also unsere Arbeit der Wissenschaftler alles super, aber da gehört der Apparat genauso dazu, wir sehen das als ganzes?
Also eine RWTH Aachen oder eine TU München die können es sich auch leisten, mal ein Projekt abzulehnen, wenn es sich finanziell jetzt nicht rentiert. Das ist natürlich irgendwie eine gute Position für die Hochschulen.
Nach dem Motto, ihr könnt ja auch woanders forschen.
Ja genau.
Da soll es eigentlich hinkommen.
Die sagen, wir sind so gut, wenn ihr mit uns zusammenarbeiten wollt, dann hat das auch seinen Preis. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch ein richtiges Verhältnis. Also Hochschulen und Unternehmen sollen sich ja auch auf Augenhöhe begegnen und die Unternehmen sollen ja auch den Preis dafür bezahlen, der angemessen ist dafür.
Wie entwickelt sich denn jetzt das mit den Drittmitteln? Ich meine, es ist stark gestiegen, geht das jetzt ewig so weiter? Ist irgendwann diese Drittmittel-Forschungsvergabe der Normalfall für Professuren?
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt unendlich weitergeht. Also wir sind schon bei einem recht guten Volumen angekommen. Wenn man sich die Hochschulen anguckt und fragt, ist das jetzt eigentlich passend, ist es zu viel Drittmittel, sind es zu wenig Drittmittel? Dann sagen die so im Durchschnitt, so ist es eigentlich wie es ist gerade ganz gut.
Kann man das irgendwie quantifizieren, welchen Anteil das so ausmacht?
Drittmittel sind ungefähr ¼ des Gesamtvolumens.
Okay, das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge. Zumal es ja auch den Professoren eine Menge auflastet. Also neben der eigentlichen Forschung und Lehrtätigkeit kommt ja dann im Prinzip immer noch dieses ganze Akquirieren, Beantragen etc. Durchführen, Begleiten noch mit dazu, was ja einfach auch eine ganze Menge zusätzlicher Arbeit darstellt.
Zumal man sehen muss, dass viele der Forschungsförderer nicht gerade bürokratische Leichtgewichte sind. Also da hat man natürlich in der Tat eine ganze Menge mit der Abwicklung des Förderprogramms dann auch zu tun. Man braucht auch Leute, die sich damit wirklich auskennen. Insofern klar …
Die es aber auch gibt an den Universitäten?
Die es auch gibt, ja. Nichts desto trotz bleibt natürlich auch viel bei den Forschern selber hängen. Und also aus Forschersicht ist es natürlich nachvollziehbar, dass man sagt, ich möchte diesen Verwaltungskram nicht haben, ich möchte die Gelder für meine Forschung haben, weil die Forschung ist gut, was ich hier anzubieten habe. So aus staatlicher Sicht kann man natürlich durchaus auch zurecht sagen, wir wollen aber auch sehen, was die Gesellschaft am Ende rausbekommt, wenn wir hier die Forschung finanzieren, dann gibt es auch ein gewisses gesellschaftliches Interesse und das muss auch nachvollziehbar belegt werden, dass wir hier irgendwie gute Forschung betreiben. Forschung betreiben, die auch am Ende den Menschen etwas bringt oder die sich ökonomisch rentiert. Die also gewisse gesellschaftliche positive Impulse auch in die Landschaft setzt.
Und darüber gleicht sich das im Prinzip dann auch wieder aus?
Ja man braucht ein System, was beide Elemente hat. Also das Element der freien Forschung, die jetzt kein besonderes Anwendungsziel im Blick hat. Die auch nicht vorgibt, welcher Bereich jetzt besonders vielversprechend ist, sondern wirklich so von der Idee des Forschers kommend die Freiheit bietet, Dinge wirklich neu zu entdecken. Weil Drittmittel steuern natürlich Forschung. Also die Forscher gehen in die Bereiche, wo die großen Fleischtöpfe sind. Und wenn ich jetzt nur noch über diese Drittmittel forsche, dann habe ich natürlich auch die Gefahr, dass so ganz neue innovative Ideen dann nicht mehr draus entstehen.
Weil einfach die Grundlagenforschung darunter leidet?
Über die Drittmittel wird auch Grundlagenforschung gefördert. Also die DFG fördert Grundlagenforschung.
Aber also sozusagen nur das was gerade das hippe Thema ist?
Genau, sie gibt natürlich Forschungsbereiche vor.
Also heute kann man prima unterwegs sein, wenn man mit Graphen was macht, aber das machen ja auch nicht alle.
Eben genau. Und man sieht das ja auch immer, bestimmte Forschungsbereiche, die man vor Jahren dann abgebaut hat, weil man dachte, ach das lohnt sich nicht. Batterieforschung ist so ein Beispiel. Und plötzlich denkt man, oh bei den regenerativen Energien wäre es nicht schlecht, wenn man das auch irgendwie speichern könnte.
Ja oder bei den Smartphones. Zum Abschluss vielleicht nochmal einen Finanzierungsbereich, den wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben und der im Prinzip vor allem für junge Wissenschaftler sehr relevant ist, nämlich die Finanzierung des Studiums als solchen. Gut in Deutschland haben wir in der Regel keine grundlegenden Studiengebühren, so ganz richtig ist das nicht, weil die ein oder andere Zuzahlung ist ohnehin an vielen Universitäten Gang und Gäbe in unterschiedlichem Maße. Dazu gab es auch noch in den letzten Jahren den Trend, durchaus so etwas wie Studiengebühren auch einzuführen. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, war das aber ein ziemlicher Rohrkrepierer und die allermeisten, wenn nicht sogar alle, Studiengebühreninitiativen sind mittlerweile wieder eingestampft worden, sehe ich das richtig gerade?
Es sind tatsächlich alle eingestampft worden.
Alle okay. War nicht so der Brüller, war nicht populär.
Es wurde ja richtig Wahlkampf mit dem Thema gemacht in den Ländern. Und also als letztes haben es Niedersachsen und Bayern abgeschafft, Niedersachsen kurz nach der Wahl, nach einem Regierungswechsel und Bayern kurz vor der Wahl, um sich da nicht …
Einen Regierungswechsel einzutreten.
... gut Regierungswechsel in Bayern ist schon was besonderes. Ja aber es war politisch definitiv nicht populär, weil es sicherlich auch ja wie jede Steuer im Grunde nicht populär ist. Es wurde als zusätzliche Belastung des Bürgers wahrgenommen. Es wurde natürlich befürchtet, dass es die vom Studium abhält, die es sich eventuell nicht leisten können. Aber eigentlich haben da viele Studien auch gezeigt, dass das gar nicht der Fall ist. Also dass durch Studiengebühren die soziale Zusammensetzung sich der Studierendenschaft nicht verändert hat.
Über welchen Zeitraum? So lange liefen ja die Programme jetzt gar nicht?
Ja es gab schon einige Bundesländer, die schon über mehrere Jahre Studiengebühren eingeführt hatten. Und das war ja schon ein Live-Experiment, in dem Moment, wo ich Studiengebühren einführe, müssten ja dann diejenige, die die Sorge haben, ich kann es mir nicht leisten, müssten ja dann irgendwie in ein anderes Bundesland gehen, wo es noch keine Studiengebühren gab oder irgendwie dem Studium fernbleiben. Also dramatische Effekte hat es bei den Studiengebühren, die es in Deutschland gab, nicht gegeben. Interessanterweise scheint es jetzt ja, wenn man gewissen Umfragen da auch vertraut, durchaus auch eine Mehrheit in der Bevölkerung zu geben, die sich für Studiengebühren einsetzt oder die sagt, Studiengebühren sind sinnvoll, wenn sie denn nachgelagert bezahlt werden. Das heißt nicht während des Studiums, sondern nach dem Studium. Sprich, dann wenn ich was verdiene, kann ich natürlich einen Teil meines Einkommens auch wieder an die Hochschule zurückgeben, die mich ausgebildet hat.
Das ist ja ein Modell, was man ja in anderen Ländern auch findet, teilweise auch sehr extrem, wie in den USA zum Beispiel, wo sich dann wiederum Studenten aber auch erheblich verschulden müssen für ihr Studium.
Ja genau. Also die Studiengebühren, die in den USA verlangt werden das ist ja kein Vergleich mit dem, was wir in Deutschland mal eingeführt haben. Also die Studiengebühren hierzulande waren ja eher …
In welchem Bereich lag das so?
... bisschen bessere Symbolik. Das waren 1000 Euro in der Regel.
Semester.
Pro?
Semester. Naja.
10.000e Euro sind normal an vielen amerikanischen Spitzenuniversitäten, um das Verhältnis da zu sehen.
Und wahrscheinlich auch teilweise an privaten Universitäten hier in Deutschland?
An privaten Universitäten muss man natürlich Studiengebühren bezahlen.
In welcher Größenordnung bewegt sich das so in der Regel?
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Also die privaten Universitäten oder privaten Hochschulen muss man sagen, das meiste sind eigentlich eher Fachhochschulen, sind so divers und heterogen, auch von ihrem Anspruch her, dass man jetzt nicht sagen kann, das und das sind die Studiengebühren an privaten Hochschulen.
Aber was ist so das Maximum, was man mal zur Kenntnis genommmen haben, um mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen?
Das sind dann ähnliche Größenordnungen, wie auch international üblich.
Mehrere tausend Euro.
Also man kann da im Prinzip beliebig viel Geld ausgeben.
Okay.
Kann man, wenn man möchte, kann man das auf jeden Fall machen.
Oder kann.
Ja. Aber die privaten Hochschulen in Deutschland sind ja auch ein speziellerer Markt. Also wie gesagt, das ist ein Nischenmarkt. Und an die privaten Hochschulen in Deutschland, muss man dann auch sehen, kommen sehr viele internationale Studierende. Gerade an die großen Privatuniversitäten. Die sind gewohnt, Studiengebühren zu bezahlen. Für die ist das jetzt nicht so die große Frage, ob ich die jetzt in Deutschland an einer privaten Universität bezahle oder in England oder in den USA. Das spielt für diese Gruppe an internationalen Studierenden jetzt keine Rolle. Aber insgesamt ist natürlich schon die Frage, wer soll das Hochschulsystem finanzieren? Und eigentlich sollten es ja die finanzieren, die davon profitieren. Und das ist auf der einen Seite der Staat, keine Frage.
Wenn ich gut ausgebildete Menschen habe, dann wirkt sich das positiv aus. Sie sind seltener arbeitslos, ich muss weniger Arbeitslosenhilfe bezahlen. Sie verdienen in der Regel besser, kriege ich mehr Einkommenssteuer als Staat. Sie sind vielleicht auch ein bisschen kreativer und innovativer, zumindest hoffen wir, dass ein Studium diesen Effekt hat. Dann treibt das auch das Wachstum. Also der Staat sollte natürlich ein Interesse haben, dass Menschen studieren. Und sollte auch einen Beitrag deswegen zum Studium bezahlen. Auf der anderen Seite profitieren natürlich auch diejenigen, die ein Studium absolvieren über ein höheres Einkommen im Lebensverlauf. Also die Bildungsrenditen für ein Studium sind gut. Und die sind deutlich höher als alle anderen alternativen Anlagen, die es heutzutage gibt. Deswegen stellt sich natürlich schon die Frage, warum nicht diejenigen, die am Ende durch einen guten Job und selten auch Arbeitslosigkeit von einem Studium profitieren, auch ein bisschen was zurückgeben.
Es gibt ja auch schon Förderungsmodelle, die jetzt sich nicht unbedingt so sehr an einem Erfolg am Ende ausrichten, also Klassiker ist ja das Bafög als Sozialleistung, sozusagen als Unterstützung für die Studienzeit während man studiert. Auch dieses Bafög ist ja über die Jahrzehnte so diversen Reformen unterworfen gewesen. Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher, aber ich glaube so in den 80er Jahren war das Bafög noch eine rückzahlungsfreie Angelegenheit, mittlerweile muss unter bestimmten Bedingungen auch Geld wieder zurückgezahlt werden oder ist das immer alles, wie sieht es da gerade aus?
Nein, es muss nicht alles zurückgezahlt werden, es hängt auch davon ab, ob man es in der Regelstudienzeit beendet und von anderen Faktoren.
Und auch davon, ob man Beschäftigung findet oder nicht?
Ich glaube davon ist es erst mal unabhängig, aber das kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen. Aber das Bafög hat natürlich in den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt gewonnen. Also man hat da jetzt nicht Gelder hineininvestiert, wie es vielleicht auch angemessen gewesen wäre, wenn man sich die Preissteigerung anguckt und die Frage insgesamt, wie viele Leute studieren eigentlich heute an der Hochschule und wie viele haben vor 10-20 Jahren hier studiert. Auf der anderen Seite hat man natürlich noch mal ein System geschaffen neben dem Bafög mit dem Deutschlandstipendium, das auch zur Finanzierung von Studierenden mit beiträgt, das ist dann allerdings nicht an die sozialen Voraussetzungen gebunden, sondern eher an die Leistung auch von Studierenden. Das ist eine Prämie für besonderes Engagement.
Es geht nicht nur um Noten, es geht auch um gesellschaftliches Engagement, was Studierende leisten. Da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Kriterien. Aber das ist eine zweite Säule, die jetzt entstanden ist, die natürlich auch in der Kritik steht. Aber hier differenziert sich einfach auch das staatliche Unterstützungssystem.
Also auch das ist jetzt wieder eine Bundesleistung? Ich glaube ursprünglich kam das mal aus dem Bundesland. Ich glaube Nordrhein-Westfalen?
Ja richtig, Nordrhein-Westfalen hatte damit angefangen. Es ist ein Bundesprogramm. Aber das interessante dabei ist ja, dass es auch mit privaten Geldern gematcht wird. Das heißt die Hälfte zahlt der Staat, die andere Hälfte zahlt ein privater Förderer. Nur wenn private Förderer gefunden werden, gibt der Staat nochmal Geld obendrauf.
Also eigentlich ist es eher andersherum? Eigentlich ist es ein Stipendium, was durch die Wirtschaft getragen wird und der Staat zahlt sozusagen die Hälfte dazu, wenn das eben stattfindet.
Ja.
Welchen Umfang hat das so in etwa? Also welche Bedeutung hat das erlangt? Ich meine das gibt es jetzt seit 2011, ist also noch eine relativ frische Geschichte.
Das ist eine relativ frische Geschichte. Die Zuwachszahlen sind hoch, aber man hat am Anfang sehr ambitionierte Ziele sich gesetzt mit dem Deutschlandstipendium und hat da vielleicht auch Erwartungen geweckt, die man auch so auf die Schnelle nicht erfüllen konnte, weil in der Tat es muss sich ja erst mal entwickeln. Es muss auch sich diese Stipendienkultur entwickeln, die ist in Deutschland ja noch gar nicht so ausgeprägt. Es müssen sich auch Strukturen an Hochschulen entwickeln. Man braucht natürlich die Erfahrung und auch die Leute, die auf Unternehmen, auf Stiftungen, auf Privatleute zugehen und Gelder einwerben. Also das ist eine gewisse Anlaufphase, das ist bei so einem Projekt normal. Und das gute ist, es ist ein ganz überwiegender Teil der Hochschulen in Deutschland, die inzwischen mitmachen. Also viele Hochschulen tragen das Programm. Obwohl es für sie natürlich auch eine gewisse zusätzliche Belastung bedeutet.
Inwiefern? Weil sie da auch noch was dazugeben müssen?
Sie müssen nichts dazugeben, aber sie müssen das organisieren. Also die Stipendien werden über die Hochschulen vergeben und das bedeutet natürlich auch Verwaltungsaufwand, der in den Hochschulen anfällt.
Das heißt, wenn man so eine Förderung bekommen möchte des Deutschlandstipendiums, dann muss man sozusagen erst mal an der eigenen Universität schauen, gibt es hier eine Möglichkeit. Kann man das auch schon, bevor man da anfängt zu studieren, machen, dass es sozusagen damit auch gleich startet?
Naja eigentlich werden die Stipendien dann vergeben, wenn man dann an der Hochschule ist.
Das heißt es ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt was für Studenteneinsteiger, sondern wenn man schon einen gewissen Lauf gehabt hat und auch schon gezeigt hat, hier das und das sind meine Orientierungspunkte, da würde ich gerne weiter forschen oder mich weiter bilden lassen, dann beantragt man ein solches Stipendium?
Aber es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche Stipendien auch in Deutschland. Also es gibt ja über die politischen Stiftungen, die die Stipendien verteilen. Also der Markt an Stipendien ist so breit, dass glaube ich auch für jede Phase des Studiums man sich zumindest um etwas bemühen kann. Insofern geht es natürlich darum auch, bestimmte Lücken zu schließen. Was halt das Deutschlandstipendien noch von den anderen unterscheidet ist einfach auch die Breite, mit der man das versucht anzugehen.
Aber das sind so im Wesentlichen eigentlich so die Stützen, auf die Studierende vor allem schauen sollten. Stipendien entweder aus Stiftungen, teilweise aus politischen Stiftungen, neu das Deutschlandstipendium oder wenn man halt vielleicht noch eine andere wirtschaftliche …
Es gibt irgendwie eine ganz schöne Seite Stipendium.de da hat man einen guten Überblick, was es letztendlich so alles gibt.
My Stipendium. Schön verdenglischt.
Natürlich.
Aber okay. Eine Orientierung, auf jeden Fall was zu finden. Kein Fehler. Ja dann haben wir es jetzt glaube ich ganz gut abgeklappert. Gibt es noch irgendwas hinzuzufügen, wie sich dieser Bereich vielleicht entwickelt? Was sind so die Trends, die Sie so sehen?
Also der gute Trend ist ja eigentlich, dass die Bedeutung von Wissenschaft und Bildung politisch auf jeden Fall anerkannt ist. Auch wenn so Schlagworte wie Bildungsrepublik werden immer dazu führen, dass man so ganz genau hinguckt, sind wir wirklich so gut, wie behauptet wird? Ist ja aber auch ganz gut, wenn man genau hinguckt. Aber man kann schon sehen, dass Wissenschaft Bildung der Bereich ist, gerade wenn man sich den Bund anschaut, der die höchsten Zuwachsraten hat. Und es hat ja uns nicht geschadet in den letzten Jahren, da irgendwie viel hineininvestiert zu haben. Wir haben ja auch bestimmte wirtschaftliche Krisen ein Stück weit besser überstanden, als das andere getan haben.
Und es gibt nicht wenige, die sage, das liegt auch daran, dass wir jetzt im Bereich Innovation, Wissenschaft so gut aufgestellt waren. Also insofern dieser Trend war ein guter. Es geht natürlich jetzt auch darum, zu belegen, was erreichen wir damit? Warum ist eine Investition, ein Euro, in Wissenschaft und Bildung investiert ein guter Euro? Das kann man an verschiedenen Zahlen sich deutlich machen. Also wir haben auch mal ausgerechnet, dass 190 Milliarden regionale Wertschöpfung durch die Hochschulen generiert werden. Das ist ja dann schon ein Batzen. Denn es wird immer dieser Verteilungskämpfe auch geben. Aber der Finanzminister ist nie ein Freund irgendwie des Wissenschaftsministers. Weil der immer so unverschämte Forderungen stellt.
Die anderen wahrscheinlich auch.
Die anderen auch ja. Und die Hochschulen sind auch immer in harten Verhandlungen. Es gab jetzt ein paar ganz gute Signale im letzten Jahr, auch von einzelnen Bundesländern, so ein bisschen aus dieser Lethargie rauszukommen und langfristig orientiert Pläne aufzustellen, wie das Hochschulsystem auch in den nächsten Jahren finanziert wird. Also dass auch auch eine gewisse Zuverlässigkeit ist, dass die Hochschulen planen können. Das ist ja auch immer ganz wichtig, dass ich nicht nur weiß, wie viel habe ich in diesem Jahr, sondern vielleicht auch wie viel habe ich in fünf Jahren. Weil Forschung ist eine langfristige Aufgabe. Also gerade in der Wissenschaft kann ich nicht ein Forschungsprojekt aufbauen und das in zwei Jahren wieder abschließen. Das geht über Jahre, über Jahrzehnte. Deswegen ist Planungssicherheit in dem System sicherlich notwendig. Trotz aller Anreize, die auch wiederum sinnvoll sind, die durch die Drittmittelvergabe ja dann auch erfüllt werden.
Man muss ja auch Infrastruktur schaffen, in personeller Form oder eben auch Labore bauen, Gebäude überhaupt erst mal haben, um Forschung durchführen zu können und wenn dann nach zwei Jahren kein Bedarf mehr dafür ist, dann haben wir gleich die nächste Investitionsruine.
Absolut ja. Und wenn ich die besten suche, dann dauert das manchmal auch einen Tag länger. Wenn ich jetzt bei Unternehmen ist die Personalrekrutierung an vielen Stellen sicherlich etwas einfacher als das im wissenschaftlichen Bereich der Fall ist ja.
Ja, Pascal Hetze vielen dank für die Ausführungen.
Sehr gerne.
Ja das war sehr aufschlussreich und sehr interessant. Und damit sind wir dann am Ende angekommen hier dieser Ausgabe. Ich bedanke mich hier auch bei allen wieder für das Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Wie immer, geht bald weiter, ich sage tschüss, bis bald.